sturm auf die us-botschaft weil die
krawalle im irak weitergehen schickt
washington zusätzliche truppen ins land
berlin deutschland und die welt begrüßen
das neue jahr 2020 wirklich ein guter
sprung
karl geiger landet beim neujahrsspringen
auf platz 2 und rückt seinem traum vom
gesamtsieg nähern
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend und bekommen
im neuen jahrzehnt die heute nachrichten
machen weiter wie gehabt und kristin
otto ist auch wieder dabei genau mit dem
sport in zehn minuten guten abend im
irak war die situation lange nicht so
angespannt wie im moment zwei
ausländische mächte die usa und iran
kämpfen dort um vorherrschaft die usa
schicken hunderte zusätzliche soldaten
ins land als reaktion auf die angriffe
von demonstranten auf die amerikanische
botschaft in bagdad diese hatten
versucht in das gebäude einzudringen die
us soldaten setzten tränengas gegen die
aufgebrachte menge ein
tobias häfner berichtet die
apache-hubschrauber kommen im schutz der
dunkelheit und schießen kurz vor der
landung noch teusch körper ab wohl auch
um einen beschuss zu erschweren
diese bilder des us militärs sollen ein
signal senden lage im griff verstärkung
ist da der adressat die wütende menge
vor der us botschaft in bagdad und vor
allem die hintermänner die viele nach
wie vor in iran vermuten schließlich
wählten zwischen brennenden autoreifen
flaggen iran treue milizen munter weiter
oben auf der mauer amerikaner unten
iraker sicherheitskräfte sind inzwischen
präsent washington hat wohl auf den
tisch gehauen
wir haben den irakern klar gemacht dass
die dinge nicht so laufen wie wir das
erwarten wir werden ihnen die pflicht
unsere einrichtungen zu schützen vor
augen halten die iranische führung
verurteilt die gestrigen attacken
offiziell schießt dabei in richtung usa
wenn so etwas passiert wie in bagdad
dann twitter der typ wieder irgendwas
oder behauptet in einer rede dass iran
verantwortlich ist das stimmt nicht die
amerikaner sollten lieber erkennen dass
die ganze region sie hasst der typ
gemeint ist us-präsident trump im
silvester urlaub in florida gibt er sich
entspannt kann sich alles zu einem krieg
hochschaukeln fragen reporter
nicht dass nein ich will frieden ich mag
frieden und iran sollte ihn noch viel
mehr wollen
inzwischen hat vielleicht auch die
präsenz von mehr irakischen
sicherheitskräften wirkung gezeigt die
wütende menge vor der botschaft in
bagdad hat sich offenbar am abend
aufgelöst
auch zwischen den usa und nordkorea wird
der ton frostiger pjöngjang droht mit
einer nach eigenen worten neuen
strategischen waffe nordkoreas
machthaber kim jong il kündigte außerdem
an dass sein land nicht länger auf atom
und raketentests zu verzichten werde
einen vorübergehenden teststopp hatte
kim vor fast zwei jahren versprochen
im gegenzug wollte nordkorea unter
anderem einen ende der harten
wirtschaftssanktionen doch us-präsident
trump lehnt dies ab die neue regierung
in österreich scheint in sicht offenbar
wird es klappen mit schwarz grün
die konservative övp von sebastian kurz
und die umweltpartei hatten ja nach den
parlamentswahlen im september zusammen
gefunden
heute treffen sich beide partner zu
letzten gesprächen
inzwischen zeichnet sich auch ab in
welche partei welches ministerium
erhalten soll
ja wenn es so kommt haben sich beide
parteien offenbar stark bewegt denn
politisch sagen sie ja bisher ziemlich
weit auseinander britta hilpert oder ja
das stimmt und das macht es ja so
spannend nicht nur für österreich hier
wagt man erstmals dieses experiment aber
wie man hört hat sich die kurz partei
cvp schon mal die schlüsselministerien
gesichert finanzen außen und innen
man hört außerdem das ist wohl ein
mehrheitlich weibliches minister team
wird und ein relativ junges das
durchschnittsalter beträgt 44 jahre und
der jüngste unter ihnen ist der künftige
kanzler sebastian kurz selbst
er will morgen hier mit seinen grünen
partnern das regierungsprogramm
vorstellen dann wird man klarer sehen
wie er die gegensätze nicht nur bei
kernthemen migration und umwelt
überwinden will die grüne basis muss dem
noch am wochenende zu stimmen die gilt
auch hier in österreich nicht als
einfach und berechenbar
aber nächste woche könnte es dann
losgehen dann kann sebastian kurz den
schwierigen beweis antreten dass nicht
nur gegensätze in der politik vereinen
sondern spaltung in der gesellschaft
überwinden kann
vielen dank nach vehlen britta hilpert
ganz in den norden jetzt in einer region
die sich rasant verändert in sibirien
nach der klimawandel am ewigen eis den
russischen wirtschaftsinteressen kommt
das jedoch entgegen
die schifffahrtswege bleiben länger
eisfrei die häfen in der erdgas- reichen
regionen boomen die ureinwohner
sibiriens aber trifft der wandel
besonders hart für becker hat für eine
zdf-dokumentation die halbinsel lama
besucht
tausende kilometer sind wir durch die
arktis gereist unterwegs in einer welt
die mit ihrer ursprünglichkeit
begeistert und sich gerade rasant
verändert auf der halbinsel yamal werden
wir zeuge des größten russischen
wirtschaftsprojekts der gegenwart
gazprom hat die gasfelder von boban
ihren kokon in rekordzeit erschlossen
feuer hitze und metall liegen sergej
hier hat der schweizer es oft mit
anderen elementen zu tun
wir werden das schon mal minus 35 grad
wo man versucht natürlich bei solchen
temperaturen nicht 1000 zu arbeiten
aber manchmal kommt es zu einer havarie
und dann musst du raus arbeiten ob du
willst oder nicht
die erwärmung der arktis spielt
russlands wirtschaft ambitionen in die
hände
die nordostpassage entlang der küste
bleibt immer öfter eisfrei sibirisches
gas wird so leichter exportierbar güter
aus china können europa schneller
erreichen durch neue helfen will
russland daran mitverdienen
gazprom hat mit boban janko wo eine
eigene kleinstadt errichtet für 3.000
mitarbeiter in der abgeschiedenheit
sibiriens sollen sie sich wie helden der
arktis fühlen während andere um ihre
heimat fürchten
im schatten der bohrtürme fällt es den
rentier nomaden zunehmend schwerer
standorte für ihre zelte und tiere zu
finden
hilfe gibt es schon aber wir geben den
gas arbeitern so viel von unserem grund
und boden ab es gibt nicht mehr genug
weidefläche wieder hier noch im süden
industrieanlagen schienen straßen
durchkreuzen das weideland der nomaden
ihre traditionellen wanderwege werden
nun bestimmt von den
wirtschaftsinteressen der fernen
russischen hauptstadt und den ganzen
film von phoebe gar sendet das zdf heute
um 23 uhr 20 die gesamte dokumentation
nordlichter finden sie auch in der zdf
mediathek im osten australiens bleibt
die lage in den brandgebieten weiter
dramatisch in mehreren küstenorten sind
die menschen immer noch von den flammen
eingeschlossen tausende sind an die
strände geflohen
nun versucht die australische armee die
betroffenen mit schiffen und flugzeugen
zu erreichen
allein in new south wales zerstörten
feuer stürme in kürzester zeit rund 180
häuser
bislang starben 14 menschen nach
deutschland in der silvesternacht sind
polizei und feuerwehr auch diesmal
tausendfach im einsatz gewesen
dabei gab es auch wieder angriffe auf
einsatzkräfte im linksalternativen
leipzig connewitz wurde bei
ausschreitungen ein beamter durch
pyrotechnik schwer verletzt das lka
ermittelt wegen versuchten mordes in
hamburg haben unbekannte einen
streifenwagen angezündet die polizisten
waren gerade im einsatz und nicht am
wagen als die täter eine scheibe am auto
einschlugen und dann den ball hinein
bars noch und in krefeld hatte die
feuerwehr einen großeinsatz im zoo dort
brannte das affenhaus komplett aus mehr
als 30 tiere kamen dabei ums leben
darunter viele menschen affen ariane
gödel
als die feuerwehr kurz nach mitternacht
im krefelder zoo eintrifft haben die
flammen bereits das meiste zerstört die
im affenhaus untergebrachten tiere sind
vermutlich im schlaf überrascht worden
30 sterben unter ihnen auch der 48
jährige massa
der älteste gorilla europas zu diesen
tieren gehörten unter anderem hoch
bedrohten menschenaffen orang utans auf
borneo flachland gorillas aus
zentralafrika und schimpansen aus
westafrika alles hoch bedrohte tierarten
die nun nicht mehr in unserem so in
dieser form und weise zu sehen sind von
dem affenhaus bleibt nur ein
stahlgerippe übrig wie durch ein wunder
könne aus diesen trümmern zwei
schimpansen leicht verletzt gerettet
werden
die polizei geht inzwischen davon aus
dass sogenannte himmelslaternen die
katastrophe ausgelöst haben
diese papierlaternen sind seit über zehn
jahren bei uns verboten
wir vermuten dass in diesem falle eine
dieser laternen hier gelandet ist wir
haben auch zeugenaussagen die dies
belegen und sagen das ganz in der nähe
mehrere laternen runtergekommen sind und
wir haben drei dieser laternen
tatsächlich auch sichergestellt
vor dem zoo trauernde menschen bei der
polizei haben sich mehrere personen
gemeldet die als mögliche
brandverursacher
frage kommen ein trauriger jahresauftakt
in krefeld für viele hat das neue jahr
aber fröhlich begonnen überall rund um
den globus begrüßten die menschen 2020
im eisigen moskau stiegen die raketen
ebenso in den nachthimmel wie an den
warmen stränden brasiliens wie hier in
rio die größte deutsche silvester party
startete in berlin am brandenburger tor
thomas concia berichtet werden das
goldene zwanziger jahre und hat sie
berlin begrüßt es regnet glitzernd es
gibt feuchte glückwünsche friedlich
feiert die hauptstadt insgesamt auch
wegen strengerer polizeikontrollen janz
berlin ist eine wolke trotz feinstaub
debatte ganz anders versucht es shanghai
china lichtzauber ohne luftverschmutzung
elektronen mit leds machen es möglich
ansonsten behangenen himmel ohne
volldampf in die zukunft hier läuft
dagegen lässt es die britische
hauptstadt richtig knallen
big bang am big ben und am london hallo
2020 mit krach und rauch bevor sie in
einem monat will heißt bei bei europa
die französische hauptstadt auch hier
ist musik drin
die champs élysées sonst entzündet sich
hier oft wut metrostationen bleiben
dicht die regierung hat der streit um
die rentenreform soll sich im jungen
jahr entscheiden
viel näher kommt man sich dagegen in new
york küsschen und konfetti viel konfetti
und sie kommt in sanften wellen ins neue
jahr
wohlstand glück für mehr menschen eine
hoffnung für wirklich goldenen 20er
jahre
tolle bilder und wir sind beim sport und
schauen wieder auf den neuen überflieger
im skispringen dessen traum lebt weiter
vom ersten deutschen gesamtsieg bei der
vierschanzentournee seit sven hannawald
2002 karl geiger flog auch bei der
zweiten station in garmisch
partenkirchen auf platz zwei der
urschrei des karl geiger nach der
nächsten herausragende leistung bei der
tournee vor 21.000 zuschauern kommt
geiger in garmisch partenkirchen wieder
auf 1 2 was er gewohnt nüchtern bewertet
sieht im zweiten durchgang so aus ein
sprung nah an der perfektion und die
landung erst nach 141,5 metern geiger
geht in führung überholt rio kobayashi
und nimmt seinem schärfsten konkurrenten
um den gesamtsieg dem japanischen
tournee- führenden sogar einige punkte
ab an das große ganze denkt geiger aber
noch nicht
tagessieger beim neujahrsspringen der
junge norweger marius lindbäck mit
schanzenrekord von 143 5 metern hinter
karl geiger wird der pole dawid kubacki
dritter
und in bester feierlaune begann auch in
japan das neue jahr für den früheren
fußball nationalspieler lukas podolski
nach zweieinhalb jahren in der dortigen
liga gewann ja im neuen olympiastadion
von tokio mit vissel kobe den
japanischen pokal
das beste zum schluss im wohl letzten
spiel für bisher kurbel feiert lukas
podolski mit weiteren ex weltmeistern
wie andres iniesta und david villa
japans kaiser pokal mit 2 zu 0 hat der
kurve unter trainer thorsten fink die
kashima antlers geschlagen für podolski
der vierte pokaltriumph im vierten land
2008 gewann er den dfb-pokal mit dem fc
bayern 2014 den fa cup mit arsenal und
beim pokalsieg mit galatasaray istanbul
traf er 2016 sogar zum 1 0 endstand
podolskis sportliche zukunft ist offen
beim ersten fc köln wird sein name
gehandelt aber auch für olympia in tokio
ist im gespräch wo der dfb drei spieler
einsetzen darf die älter als 23 sind
york police 34 das paket muss passen
sagt er
ja und wo mehrere lottozahlen passen das
erfahren sie jetzt die gewinnzahlen
lauten 7 13 17 37 42 44 und die
superzahl 8 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 7 fehlen noch die
wetteraussichten für morgen im westen
gibt es dichte wolken aber es bleibt
meist trocken sonst nach teils zäher
nebel viel sonne höchstwerte 0 bis 8
grad
das war es von uns nächste nachrichten
in diesen programmen gegen viertel nach
elf und jetzt wünschen wir alle hier in
ein gutes neues jahr
[Musik]